search-and-rescue efforts are underway
in Southern California where deadly
mudslides wiped away dozens of homes
storms and mudflows killed at least 15
people in Santa Barbara County they're
concerned that the number could go much
higher more than 20 people are still
missing emergency crews say they
received more than 600 calls for help in
a three-hour period yesterday Carter
Evans is in hard-hit Montecito that is
about two hours northwest of Los Angeles
Carter good morning good morning so I
want you to imagine what this must have
been like it would have been about this
time yesterday morning about 4 o'clock
in the morning it's dark you're sound
asleep and then all of a sudden out of
nowhere this comes barreling down the
hill right toward your home take a look
at what it can do to a home when it
comes by you can see the front of this
home was ripped right off now the mud
was Unleashed early Tuesday due to a
combination of torrential rainfall and
recent wildfires in one area almost an
inch of rain fell in 15 minutes it
buried homes and roads in an area
scorched by the Thomas fire last month
now mudslides are common after a
wildfire because the trees and
vegetation that had held the soil in
place burned in the fire the heavy rains
loosens the soil and then it begins
sliding downhill now as the flow picks
up speed it also collects rocks and
trees and pushes them at up to 20 miles
per hour the debris damages and destroys
homes while the mud begins to harden now
once that happens the search of rescue
effort becomes very very difficult more
than 50 people had to be rescued by
helicopters including a family of five
and there are still many people who are
unaccounted for
so those rescues are going to continue
today
John thank you Carter